NARRATOR: Talk about
counting sheep.
There must be hundreds
of them on this hill.
And this black dog,
standing front and center,
driving the herd.
And the most amazing thing about
this image is the perspective.
Just how do you capture
a moment like this?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sometimes to get
the shot you want,
you have to be willing to get
your hands dirty like this guy.
ANDREW FLADEBOE: Hello, my
name is Andrew Fladeboe.
I'm an artist currently
based in Minneapolis.
I'm often lying on the ground
to get the angle I want,
covered in mud, and
I'm pretty sure I
look like a crazy person.
NARRATOR: In this
case, Andrew was
lying in a field in New
Zealand's South Island,
taking pictures of working dogs.
ANDREW FLADEBOE:
This particular dog
is a Huntaway, a unique dog
to New Zealand which is not
defined by physical
characteristics, but by the job
they perform.
They excel at
moving sheep uphill,
and in close quarters
using their loud bark.
[DOG BARKING]
We are moving a
few thousand sheep
from one end of the
property to their homestead.
It was quite foggy, so
we almost didn't go out,
as it was hard for the
shepherds to see the sheep.
NARRATOR: It turns out that
Andrew is somewhat of an expert
when it comes to capturing
working dogs an action.
In fact, he's traveled
the world documenting
the unique relationship that
has developed over centuries
between man and dog, in a series
called "Shepherd's Realm".
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW FLADEBOE:
During my first volume
of the "Shepherd's
Realm" series,
I took a portrait of a
dog named [INAUDIBLE]
in the highlands of Scotland.
To me, the picture
represented the dog
in such a noble
and individual way.
It was special, and
I figured that I
could do something really
interesting and new
if I focused only on dogs.
The more I researched dogs,
the more I fell in love
with them and their history.
NARRATOR: Andrew's work has
taken him across the globe,
allowing him a rare
insight into how different
cultures rely on working dogs.
ANDREW FLADEBOE: Through my
adventures photographing dogs,
I've learned so much about
them and their importance
to humanity across different
cultures and demographics.
One fact that stands out
is how devoted the dogs are
to their owners and handlers.
They would do anything
that is asked of them,
and work nonstop through any
kind of whether or terrain.
I remember looking
at a sheepdog's face
as he looked up at his owner
after a rough 10 hour muster.
It was filled with pure
joy and dedication.
NARRATOR: And it may
be a cliche to say it,
but Andrew's portraits
of working canines
are a testament to the
phrase, man's best friend.
ANDREW FLADEBOE: To me they
represent God's greatest gift
to humanity-- a species
sagacious and noble,
willing to do whatever
we ask of them,
and only asking for
some food and a pat
on the head in return.
NARRATOR: Hey, everyone.
If you'd like to be
featured on our show,
send us a link to
your photography
website below in the comments.
If you don't have a site
and are looking to make one,
get a domain name at domain.com.
It's affordable,
reliable, and easy to use.
And because you
watch our show, you
can get 20 percent off new
domains, web hosting, and email
by using the code HAPPENED
when you check out.
And if you liked
this video, don't
forget to check out
this one on what
it's like to get this close
to a great white shark.
MAN: The photo itself--
taken from inside the cage--
shows the shark having managed
to grab the bait before anyone
had a chance to react.
The end result is this powerful
image of it leaping out
of the water with its prize.
NARRATOR: And, as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]